[Musik]
es ist noch gar nicht so lange her da
war istanbul wie immer voll laut
chaotisch und
[Musik]
ist dann wohl die 16 millionen metropole
am bosporus ist jahrtausende altes
bindeglied zwischen morgenland und
abendland seit ihrer gründung ist die
stadt begegnungsstätte der kulturen ist
dann wohl lebt von seinen menschen
doch diese bilder wirken heute wie aus
einer anderen zeit
[Musik]
totale ausgangssperre an den wochenenden
seit das corona virus die welt gefangen
hält ist die schöne vom bosporus wie
erstarrt
[Musik]
istanbul die stadt der träume und der
träumer schläft nun selbst
istanbul sie total verlassen aus so als
ob die menschen aus der stadt geflohen
wären
der taksim-platz die istiklal einkaufs
promenade menschenleer
[Musik]
eine stadt wie istanbul eine
millionenstadt die sonst 24 stunden lang
auf den beinen ist so zu erleben
das ist einfach unbeschreiblich
die metropole zwischen den kontinenten
hält den atem an
[Musik]
die sonst übervollen plätze der stadt
sind leer
es ist als sei istanbul plötzlich
verstummt
[Musik]
vor allem auf den abend touren sagt
kapitän ismailow fahre er manchmal ein
leeres schiff nur ein paar berufspendler
trauen sich an den wochentagen auf seine
fähre die touristen in istanbul schon
lange verlassen
die fähren sind eines der wichtigsten
transportmittel in istanbul vor der
korona krise hatten wir rund 15.000 fall
ist dein tag heute sind es vielleicht
gerade noch 1500 personen
es gibt für alle genug platz um den
vorgeschriebenen abstand einzuhalten
die fahrgäste sind alle älter als
zwanzig und jünger als 65 für diese
altersgruppen hat in die türkische
regierung schon vor wochen
ausgangssperren verhängt seitdem hat
sich ist dann wohl verändert ich denke
es ist eine großartige gelegenheit eine
stadt wie istanbul einmal so leer zu
sehen auf der anderen seite aber macht
es mich traurig diese einsamkeit das hat
istanbul eigentlich nicht verdient
das wird hoffentlich bald vorbei sein
wir merken erst jetzt wie schön das
leben vorher war alles ist jetzt so
anstrengend geworden okay es gibt zwar
keine staus mehr und die straßen sind
leer aber alle sitzen auch bei guten
wetter nur noch zu hause und in allen
bereichen ist leben einfach nur noch
anstrengend
seit das corona virus auch die türkei
erreichte nutzen immer weniger menschen
u bahn busse oder fähren aus angst sich
anzustecken
in der jetzigen situation wünschen wir
uns nichts mehr als die istanbuler
wieder auf das wasser zu bekommen
die leute sitzen zu hause aber ich sage
ihnen ganz offen
wir möchten sie wieder mit dem er ihnen
den wunderschönen blick auf den bosporus
zeigen wir warten voller sehnsucht auf
sie
[Musik]
jeff pash wird seit 35 jahren taxi hätte
mir mal einer gesagt dass ich eines
tages in istanbul von a nach b kommen
ohne einmal zu bremsen mein chef geht
ich hätte ihn ausgelacht und schaut euch
die galater brücke an rechts und links
standen je früher die angler und haben
fische gefangen
die standen nebeneinander keinen meter
abstand auf beiden seiten der brücke
standen massen von leuten chef geht hat
ein hobby er fotografiert die menschen
die er auf seinen fahrten durch istanbul
sieht vor allem die obdachlosen einer
von ihnen ist karl d gerade wurde er aus
dem knast entlassen wo er zwei jahre
lang wegen körperverletzung saß wegen
der korona krise ließ die regierung
90.000 strafgefangene früher laufen
kadir war einer von ihnen
du brauchst keine angst zu haben die
haben uns drei tage lang allen möglichen
tests unterzogen
die haben einen bluttest gemacht und
habe speichelproben genommen alle die
negativ waren haben sie gehen lassen die
stadt hat sich in der zwischenzeit
wahnsinnig verändert
die straßen sind abends menschen mehr
chef gerd will kd abends wieder treffen
um ein paar fotos zu machen
in der zwischenzeit will er uns sein
lieblings viertel zeigen
kabasi ein stadtteil in den viele kurden
und roma leben ein engeres ein
arbeiterviertel alaba hat etwas
familiäres sagt chef ted auch einige
seiner besten kumpels leben
ich kenne teuer sei 20 25 jahren
dieses viertel ist berühmt für seine
miesmuscheln alle miesmuscheln die er in
istanbul findet stammen von hier früher
war da ja ein kleiner miesmuschel
verkäufer dann hat er sich vergrößert
und ist ein geschäftsmann geworden
aber jetzt sieht das wegen der korona
krise ganz anders aus er wird euch
erzählen
ich wollte letztens einen kredit
aufnehmen und habe keinen bekommen
obwohl ich eine eigene firma habe das
was die regierung in den medien erzählt
es doch alles gelogen
von wegen finanzielle hilfe wo die
spreche nicht nur von mir
es gibt andere menschen die ist noch
dringender nötig haben
du kannst hier niemanden dazu bringen
wegen corona die ganze zeit im haus zu
bleiben
das ist die östliche mentalität selbst
wenn ein krieg ausbrechen würde
würden diese menschen vor ihre tür gehen
sie gehen ja auch nicht viel weiter als
bis vor die eigene tür am abend fährt
chef geht zur verabredung mit cardio die
straßenkinder und obdachlosen sind das
dunkle gesicht der glitzernden metropole
kadir und die anderen aus seiner gang
leben im matsch carpark die polizei
kennt sie lässt sie in ruhe
doch auf der straße herrscht ein
brutaler überlebenskampf und
schlafplätze und drogen
der tod ist für uns etwas alltägliches
corona hin oder her
durch unseren drogenkonsum sind unsere
lungen sowieso dahin natürlich habe ich
angst und ich hoffe es trifft niemanden
von uns der auf der straße chef geht
muss sich beeilen um wieder
zurückzukommen ab mitternacht gilt über
das wochenende die zweitägige
ausgangssperre
[Musik]
weil wir eine sondergenehmigung haben
dürfen wir am nächsten tag auf die
straße und drehen ein istanbul wie man
es in seiner über 2000-jährigen
geschichte noch nie gesehen hatte
[Musik]
während der ausgangssperre besuch mehr
chef geld zu hause seine frau will nicht
dass er ab montag wieder taxi fährt zu
gefährlich sagt sie auch wenn ich es
nicht tue können wir unsere miete nicht
mehr zahlen mein chef hat und dann zeigt
er uns die bilder die am abend vorher
aufgenommen hat irgendwie fühle er sich
gerade wie in einem horrorfilm
ich mache mir sorgen um die menschen
nicht die straßen werden irgendwann
wieder voll sein ist es aber was wird
mit den obdachlosen was wird mit den
ganzen arbeitslosen die bekommen ja kaum
finanzielle unterstützung viele leben
von der hand in den mund
den leuten geht es sehr schlecht
ein paar kilometer weiter ruft imam
abdul samad zum mittagsgebet in seiner
leeren dede man moschee im stadtteil st
[Musik]
wir haben sonst in der moschee mit
unserer gemeinde fünfmal am tag kontakt
gehabt jetzt aber sind die moscheen für
gemeinsame gebete geschlossen
die gläubigen dürfen während der woche
nur einzeln hierherkommen und beten für
uns geistliche ist das natürlich
schwierig durch corona fühlen wir uns
jetzt eher allein der imam hat eine
corona spendenaktion organisiert die ihn
zumindest mit einigen seiner schäfchen
wieder zusammenbringt montagmorgen die
ausgangssperre ist vorbei die
bedürftigen kommen um sich im vorraum
seiner moschee hilfsgüter abzuholen
vorher müssen sie sich in eine liste
eintragen wir mein mann und ich sind
beide freiberufler und im moment ist
alles zum stillstand gekommen das hier
ist das einzige was sie an unterstützung
bekommen
gott kennt keine grenzen
wir müssen halt schauen wie lange diese
nahrungsmittel toilettenpapier putzzeug
sogar schuhe
jeder darf sich sieben dinge nehmen doch
so genau schaut abdullah mit nicht hin
denn täglich kommt nachschub von
spendern viele liefern ihre einkäufe
direkt an seiner moschee ab wir haben
einen bericht über den imam und seine
aktion im fernsehen gesehen und dann
haben wir seine moschee im internet
gesucht und jetzt bringen wir ebenso
viel unsere finanzielle situation
erlaubt der imam nutzt alle plattformen
postet seine spendenaufrufe erfolgreich
auf twitter und die menschen geben was
sie entbehren können
hier hat jemand nur ein glas sirup
geschickt und ein anderer ein karton mit
toilettenpapier
wir glauben daran dass wir auch diese
göttliche prüfung überstehen wird
wir müssen nur geduld haben und uns an
die richtlinien halten die der staat in
dieser zeit lässt dann wird uns gott
dafür belohnen
[Musik]
denn die regierung in ankara trifft die
entscheidungen nicht er krimi mulock
bürgermeister von istanbul
er wollte härtere maßnahmen und die viel
früher denn seine stadt ist das zentrum
der pandemie in der türkei doch
präsident erdogan lehnte ab hoffte wohl
es werde schon nicht so schlimm werden
wir erreichen die mambo luca skype in
seinem büro ich glaube nicht dass diese
kurzfristigen ausgangssperren etwas
bringen das virus hat am wochenende ja
nicht frei es ist immer da und es ist
hochansteckend
nach unserer einschätzung braucht es in
istanbul eine zwei oder besser noch eine
dreiwöchige ausgangssperre und strenger
isolation nur so könnten wir die
verbreitung verlangsamte hofft dass
istanbul ab juni langsam zur normalität
zurückkehren könne
aber auch dann werde es noch monate
dauern bis die wunden verheilt sein
das ist natürlich sehr traurig ist der
wohl so still und verlassen zu sehen
andererseits erkennen wer jetzt wie
schön ist dann wohl tatsächlich ist aber
natürlich wer lieber in istanbul sehen
voller menschen die produzieren und in
frieden miteinander leben
das ist doch immer noch das beste und
das vermisse ich sehr
[Musik]
es herrscht stille am fuße des galata
turm dieses wahrzeichen istanbuls ist
seit vielen wochen schon geschlossen wir
bekommen eine sonderführung tuba jack
reacher arbeitet für istanbuls
stadtverwaltung
sie steigt mit uns die treppen des
galater thoms hoch wo sonst tausende
touristen schlange stehen ist es heute
still und leer
im restaurant wussten sie mitte märz die
stühle hochstellen hier oben hat man
beim abendessen einen tollen blick auf
istanbul sagt huber auch sie vermisst
die menschen das war hier so ein froher
und ausgelassene ort wo sich die
touristen nur so gedrängt haben hoch auf
die aussichtsplattform zu kommen aber es
ist jetzt halt leider so wie wir es
gerade erleben die geschichte dieses
turmes ist auch eine geschichte von
krisen und katastrophen aber immer hat
sich der galata turm wieder erholt er
wird sich auch von dieser katastrophe
erholen da ist sich cooper sicher
der ausblick von hier oben fast 100
meter über dem meeresspiegel ist
atemberaubend
knapp sechs euro eintritt kostet es
sonst den turm zu erklimmen
die touristen spülen millionen in die
stadtkassen geld das fehlt
als der bürgermeister eine eigene
spendenaktion für seine klamme stadt
starten wollte wurde ihm das von der
regierung in ankara verbot
die ganze welt erlebt gerade eine
unglaubliche veränderung wie gesagt der
galata turm hat brände erdbeben und
kriege überlebt er hat vieles
überstanden
aber das was wir jetzt erleben ist etwas
ganz anderes
es ist als ob wir die stadt den vögeln
anvertraut haben
vielleicht erholt sich jetzt die natur
ein wenig von uns menschen
alle haben sich in ihre häuser
verkrochen istanbul es so still und
ruhig aber ohne menschen ist es doch
alles ein wenig traurig es sind bilder
für die geschichtsbücher
die moscheen treffpunkte der gläubigen
auch im fastenmonat ramadan
menschenleeren keine angler keine
touristen auf der galata brücke
die schöne vom bosporus schläft und alle
warten auf den tag an dem istanbul
wieder aufwacht und so wird wie früher
so voll so laut und so bunt
[Musik]